hello everyone and welcome to pi data
global 2021 my name is camila i'm going
to be your moderator for for this
session and i'm very happy to be here i
would like now to welcome our uh
speakers
and i would like to welcome uh valentin
danchev ben marvik brandeis marshall
kirsty whittaker sarri stodd
and they are going to give us a workshop
on building responsible data science
workflows transparency reproducibility
and ethics by design
welcome
maybe i'll kick us off do a quick intro
and then we'll go around
um
hi everyone i'm sarah stout um i'm an
assistant professor of mathematics in at
bucknell university but i'm a
statistician in the math sitting in the
math department
um the things i'm sort of bringing to
this conversation today i just want to
give some sort of prompts where my
head's at with this sort of topic is i
teach undergraduates right and so
i'm when i'm thinking about like
reproducibility responsibility is sort
of like you either are good and you do
it 100 or you're bad and you don't and
i'm wondering if there's a way that we
could sort of build these sort of
checkpoints that are more feasible um
and maybe less demoralizing as learners
and also teachers of this when we're
teaching this alongside of some content
it would be nice to have some milestones
like good enough for this level good
enough for this level what is good
enough um just so that there's not sort
of this like yes you're good no you're
bad
um some other things i'm thinking about
is that i personally
really hate constraints when i'm doing
the exploratory phase of a new project i
know i should be reproducible i know i
should be thinking about all those
things but i just want to like be
creative for a second and so i'm
wondering if there are sort of guide
rails that we could set ourselves up for
success in that exploratory phase that
we're when we're ready to go to that
more
rigorous phase where we're ready for
that are there sort of some nice
on-ramps that don't feel too
constraining at the beginning and the
last thing i want to just have us think
about is
the workflow we is very data related
like our data pipelines our analysis but
i'd also encourage us to think about how
that workflow includes the communication
aspect at the end how do you have a
responsible workflow of collaborative
writing how do you make that work when
you all of your collaborators have
different
experiences different software you're
working for different journals that have
their own weird constraints that is part
of the workflow too and i'm wondering if
it falls under the same sort of theory
of what we want from that sort of
responsible workflow not forgetting that
writing is a big part of what we do too
um so i'll stop there i'm like looking
forward to hearing from you all and
learning from you all and
somebody else please take it away
my name is valentin dunchev and i'm a
lecturer at the
university of essex
where i'm
interested in computational social
science and open science reproducibility
and i'm also data science educator where
i
try to and strive to to teach inclusive
accessible reproducible data science
students
and i've been
thinking about those problems how we can
establish and
in a way scaffold or
design workflows
that
incorporate
incorporate different principles of
transparency reproducibility
but even more going earlier in research
design in terms of
um pre-registration for example and
thinking about more uh
about research design and how we select
variables and also on the other end of
data analysis
in terms of data sharing but also equity
and
fairness and documenting biases so it
goes
in a way beyond as we typically will
think about
data analysis and i i think
what is why i'm so excited about this
panel and this cross-disciplinary uh
panel discussion is that communities
have established so many different
tools and techniques to enable
reproducibility and transparency
and also
for
software sustainability and reusability
and form
for
cod testing and
as well
evaluating for for harms and fairness
and it's so important now for those
communities to
to talk together and to chat and to
exchange ideas
and um
in a way move forward the debate in in a
few different ways
one is what
those
responsible data science workforce
should look like how we should design
them
what principles we should integrate them
and also what are the current gaps
challenges what kind of problems still
exist but workforce
do not
address them it one way how i typically
think about this workforce is as this
extended cognition
scaffolding where
it goes beyond data analysis and we can
organize those tools
like notebooks and
um conversion control and
environments in a way that
um
foster
responsible data science foster
reproducibility faster transparency and
i know that many people in this panel
have established some of those tools
techniques concepts
that bring this
to bear on good research practices
and
yeah so i think it will be it will be
great to
to chat about those and uh but also move
beyond and and and see what would be how
this
workforce could be inclusive as well
more collaborative to bring different
people together i think the most the
more
workforce responsible data science
workflows are
designed in a way that people can enter
that will be that will be wonderful and
collaborate
that would be a great and also what kind
of incentives from a sociological
perspective what kind of incentives
are are not yet there um
we've heard a lot about open science and
that some of the incentives in academia
industry may not be aligned and so that
would be also a
um
issue with the with the word false and
uh and yeah and that and finally future
oriented
what will be the future workforce do we
need one single workflow which is
probably
unrealistic or
discipline specific
or specific data analysis or those that
enable cooperation and i think these are
open questions that it will be great to
explore and
learn more from each other
yes hi hi everyone uh my name is tibor
eston
um
so i'm actually a research software
engineer at the university of oxford in
the in the uk um and what that means is
that i
basically collaborate with researchers
across the university um so not on a
specific field but very much across the
university
uh on on different software projects um
and these collaborations they they can
be very varied and basically it goes
from
coaching researchers on software best
practices
uh all the way to
longer term software development
software maintenance um
optimization refactoring etc etc
um
just a word about my background i i do
have an experience short experience in
in research i have a phd in physics and
that experience is helping me every day
as a research software engineer because
my job is all about
community communicating with researchers
understanding
the research contests um the
limitations um
the the scientific questions um
and the pressures sometimes that they
face that apply to the to the software
being being written and to work with
them
to make sure that the software that is
supporting
the research or sometimes the software
that is that is the output of the
research can be is as high quality
as possible and therefore enabling you
know high quality research um
so
i'm part of a relatively small group at
oxford so we are very we're not a
separate company we are
um a group within oxford um
and um with there are about
seven of us and so our mission is really
to provide the software engineering
expertise that that
that's really useful for for researchers
and we do this in many two ways the
first one is as i said collaborating
directly with researchers
um so
day to day i would spend my day on on
two projects for instance um
sometimes in in very different areas so
it's interesting to kind of compare and
see how do biologists do things and how
to chemistry things and physicists and
psychologists
um
and the second aspect of my work is
training um
so i
we tend to do as a group and i tend to
do a as a research software engineer
training
we organize courses for researchers to
learn how to for instance write tests so
package their python
package to our scripts learn how to
share their software usability systems
etc etc and
that's that's we can see that is very
this is very useful people people people
actually
you know enjoy this and think that's
useful but obviously we're facing
um the incentive problem and people go
back to their research and it's hard for
it for them to actually spend the time
and effort to learn on their own and
then apply that um so that's that's
something that
you both mentions sir and valentin and
something that's something that i would
very much like to talk about
and lastly i think uh the last aspect of
my
my role as a research software
engineering not especially at oxford
generally
is to advocate for better software
practices in academic research
um
i don't mean by that that i think
researchers do a bad job i don't think
that's true
but
i think that
through more software training
and more software advocacy it could be
perhaps more efficient
more sustainable and also more enjoyable
um
so that that sort of advocacy is
something that i do locally at oxford
through
through local reproducibility
initiatives reproducible research oxford
and also at a larger scale through the
software sustainability institute which
is a uk-based academic institute that
promotes um
best better better software and for
better research
so yeah i'd like for just for more
researchers to to be aware that research
software engineering exists and
that that that they can you know
collaborate with researcher for
engineers uh to both learn more about
software best practices and also benefit
from software engineering disease from
people who also know research
i think that's a that's that's the key
point
and you know if you don't have research
software engineers in your institution
um then you could just ask your
institution to say well we need software
support um and these sort of like this
position exists look at the uk and
germany and
in norway in the u.s they are researched
for engineers and it's working pretty
well so um
just don't hesitate to ask
just you know just it sounds easy but
you know just great areas of positions
and so hi everyone i'm christy whitaker
i
am the program director for the tools
practices and systems research program
at the alan turing institute which is
the uk's national institute for data
science and artificial intelligence
i feel like that sentence is one of the
longest that i ever that i ever say
um
the tools so the the alan turing
institute has multiple domains of um of
research so we have lots of applied
areas in defense and security urban
analytics
health and medical sciences um
data centric engineering data science
for science public policy i'm probably
forgetting one which is very
embarrassing
and you can think about the tools
practices and systems program as being a
cross-cutting program
that's designed to sort of
support the transfer of knowledge across
each of those different um areas so for
example
uh you might have really great
geospatial knowledge inside of the urban
analytics program
but there will also be climate
scientists inside of the data science
for science program that stands for
science and humanities and so it's the
tools practices and systems programs
responsibility to make sure that folks
in column a know about the folks in
column b
and have ways to share expertise
and then what we really want to do
is
exactly that activity
but on a global scale
and i think the open source ecosystem so
like the pi data ecosystem and but also
you know the the r ecosystem the julia
ecosystem um
so many of these packages already exist
so much of this knowledge is already
available
but one of the very very hard parts is
the discovery of that information
and so i'm going to build on on points
that i think all three of the panelists
before me have said about the incentives
and so what we're actually trying to do
is
is specifically hire people either as
community managers
or as what we're calling research
application managers so these are uh
inspired by the the role of a product
manager in a tech field and sort of
pivoting those ideas to um to academia
and they will be people who connect up
with users with stakeholders and make
sure that we're not just building
something that's kind of cool and
interesting
we're actually building something that
has a need that somebody else actually
wants
and that the thing that we build so i'm
thinking of a software package but it
could also be
an ethics framework
it could be a trained algorithm but
importantly it has to have that user
stakeholder engagement right from the
beginning and it could be something as
basic as it doesn't install on my
machine there's no documentation to
explain to me how to use it
or
it doesn't quite work for my specific
use case
can we help as part of an open source
ecosystem can we help to sort of
add in those features that would allow
us to use it
and
one of the other things that i wanted to
sort of bring to this discussion
although i want to be very clear i
absolutely wholeheartedly agree with
everything that every other panelist has
said but but another dimension i wanted
to sort of bring up um the concept of
continuous integration so where to pi
data workshop probably lots of people
but not necessarily everyone
will associate continuous integration as
automated testing probably on a remote
computer somewhere
and um you know if you run continuous
integration on your github repository
for example then every time you make a
change your test suite is going to say
what was that change
let me make sure that we're still
getting the same answers from everything
that we were expecting as we did before
and
what i want to sort of the reason i want
to kind of reflect on that a little bit
is
i would love for us to
consider the whole of the scientific
life cycle
as multiple
continuous integration cycles
rather than something that has a
beginning
and something that has an end because i
think a that's a much better way of sort
of incorporating feedback it's a much
faster way of bringing in contributors
and sort of scaling out what's going on
it allows you to pivot so one of the
great things that is is highly
disincentivized at the moment but very
very common
is that you have an idea you work very
hard on it
and then about three quarters of the way
through your set let's say two year
project
you realize that this is a problem
that's already been solved but you
didn't know enough to sort of discover
that github repository or that tool that
existed
and what do you do then do you just sort
of like close your eyes and say i was
already in the middle of my two-year
project so i need to keep going here and
i have to publish something and that
that sort of
feeds this not invented here kind of
bias that we see a lot in the way that
people behave and we also see this sort
of focus on novelty and a kind of
fragmenting of the tools that we're
building rather than a cohesion across
an ecosystem
and then the other thing that i want to
sort of bring in on this continuous
integration this kind of continuous
reflection and feedback
is that although the phrase isn't used
in um
in in groups that are thinking about
ethical responsibilities
around and the use of artificial
intelligence it is absolutely core to
most of the recommendations that you
should always be
engaging with stakeholders
and you must always be reflecting
as you go along and so one of the things
that i would really really love to sort
of see
the the data intensive research
community to move towards is that we we
stop having
access to sensitive data or building
large computational models we stop
having kind of one ethical review
process gate that has to be
passed through or hurdled right at the
beginning of the project or right at the
end of the project which has its own own
sort of huge amounts of problems if
you've already invested a massive amount
of time
but what if we set up multiple
collaborative gates
and we were really thoughtful
about exactly what we can promise and
importantly what we cannot promise
around uh biases in the data around the
representativeness of the data around
the fairness or how the how the
algorithm is going to be deployed and we
don't try and make some great big
promise right at the beginning
we make a sensible promise and we
continue to iterate on that promise uh
thinking responsibly as we go and i
would love for us to sort of that's just
the thing that i wanted to bring to this
discussion is
how can we start to move from a linear
engagement in um in research projects to
that more either ecosystem
level or that continuous dimension in
time
and the person who's right next to me on
the screen is brandeis so i'm going to
i'm going to hand to you
all right thank you chrissy um
that was a great framing um hello
everyone my name is brandeis marshall
she her doctor
if you like that adopt it
i lead data at x it is a
data executive training firm so we tend
to work in the adult education space so
people who are currently in the
workforce who are dealing with these
problems like you are and trying to do
our best in order to provide
um
workshops seminars and pathways in order
to uh do a little bit of what um
christie was talking about
which is how to interject the
the the data practices and to look at it
in in five different lanes and that
happens to be in the collection phase
during the storage phase the third
happens to be
um
analysis which is the biggest one and
fourth is visualization and fifth is
storytelling or communication so where
at each point do we need to have
more
intentional talks about equity and how
do we then operationalize them
so when it comes to this topic of
responsible data science
workflows i like to take a step back and
really try to refocus um the
conversation and
and where we work so well in is talking
about who is the most vulnerable where
are the communities
and what's the impact to those
communities first and then reverse
engineer everything else so as someone
that has
spent my entire career in computer
science
and as an educator
there's a lot of intentionality when it
comes to the mechanics of tech
right how do you code what step which
algorithm what is the process
what is the linear process
and then what are the pain points but
the nature of the work is what tends to
not be talked about too much within the
tech spaces and i'm trying to elevate
that conversation
not only on my twitter um but also in a
book that i'm writing
in order to make sure that people are
looking at who is the most vulnerable
and trying to center their experience
before even building the tech because
there are times in which tech doesn't
need to be built the tech part is
complicating matters so when it comes to
responsibility the responsibility
aspect to me kind of fall falls under
three avenues um one happens to be trans
um
happens to be transparency
how transparent is the technology and to
the earlier point i think several people
made about open science there is a lot
of open software
libraries and platforms that haven't
really been vetted through an ethical or
equitable lens
and so it does cause harm
and people are using it every day so we
need to have more transparency of
existing proprietary and open source
software secondly
there is accountability and that is
accountability from the big tech down to
the small tech about what are their
processes
where are they having um conversations
and who is included in those
conversations not only people in the
community in which it will affect
especially the most vulnerable but also
making sure that tech teams don't just
have people from stemi degrees that
there needs to be people from social
sciences and humanities in in these
spaces having these conversations and
being active members as part of
development teams
the days of tech people just talking to
tech people needs to be over
o the er
and because it is frustrating um as a
tech person is frustrating to say hey
that tech is not needed and then i get
into arguments because someone just
wants to create and write code and it's
not necessary um shout out to facial
recognition in all spaces that don't
need to happen and then the last thing
that i'll say
is that the third area that i think we
need to work on is really in tech policy
and and that is a long-term plan i know
policy especially government wise works
slowly but it is something that i
believe is necessary
in order to do to be another level of
reinforcement to ensure that tech stays
focused on being transparent and
accountable um and i don't think that's
going to happen with just a couple of
misfits
or like i like i like to call myself a
rebel tech person
is not going to be helpful we need to
have a collective
concerted intentional effort
so that's my thoughts i'd love to have
conversations about all of these things
especially prioritizing the most
vulnerable in these spaces and who those
most vulnerable are
with that said i'll pop it over to ben
in order to give his introduction
thank you so much and thanks to all of
you for i'm typing away furiously taking
notes or interesting things you're all
saying this is fantastic so i'm a
professor in a professor of archaeology
at the university of washington
uh in here in seattle on the unseated
lands of the duwamish i'm also a senior
fellow in the e science institute which
is our data science kind of community
here at uw and the director of a new
interdisciplinary minor in data science
which after one year is now almost one
of the largest minors on the campus of
undergraduates and one of the
distinctive features of that now that i
want to share is we we have a
requirement that students not only take
a class from a list of data skills
classes which are the traditional things
that you
probably imagine right away
visualization statistics machine
learning databases and so on in which we
prioritize open source tooling although
we allow classes that use closed source
software which are industry standards
but we prefer faculty to teach in python
and r and so on we also require students
to take a class from a list that we call
data studies
so these are non-technical classes they
come out of the history department
uh american indigenous studies
anthropology department where i'm in
and they're the kind of concept that
unites those is that the courses are
about an exploration of the ethics
implications historical political
philosophical um sociological
of the use of data intensive methods and
epistemologies and so this is our sort
of
concept for giving students a solid
opportunity to explore the
responsibilities
that come with data intensive work and
and being a data scientist so we don't
imagine that we will create data science
in this minor that
the miner will be a sort of stepping
stone for them to go into maybe a
master's program or something else that
will allow them a career but this data
studies requirement is a really we feel
a really unique
uh part of our program that gives them
an intensive opportunity to explore the
responsibilities around data science so
currently we're growing this program
we've got we're going to hire three new
faculty over the next two years
and at least one maybe more of those is
going to be in the humanities we just
hired an english professor who started
this year who's doing data science in
the humanities you know on large
corporate poetry and pamphlets and
ephemeral literature like that and in
our job interviews and our job ads and
interview questions we've been
specifically putting wording in there
that indicates that successful
candidates will be those who have
embraced
values and practices that enhance the
reproducibility and transparency of
their work and and how they plan to
teach that as well so we're specifically
kind of
uh documenting our priority for this and
we've had i think some great responses
amongst the candidates who perhaps have
not been
totally expecting that kind of question
and so i want to encourage all of you
not to miss these kind of opportunities
in these kind of soft
spaces maybe on the periphery of where
we usually talk about
and technical things about
the reproducibility of the work where we
can communicate our values about
transparency and reproducibility in
these kind of things like drop ads and
interviews and stuff like that
so um in my own teaching
i teach archaeology primarily at all
levels and i a common theme throughout
the empirical classes that i teach is
the concept of the research compendium
as a standard practice from small weekly
assignments the smallest little bit of
data analysis you can imagine make one
graph right through to working with phd
students and their phd dissertations the
research compendium is kind of this
distinctive concept where we try to
create as much as possible this
self-contained
archive of minimally you know one code
file one data file and that's kind of it
and toward the other end of the spectrum
it's a much you know there's a docker
file and a binder
configuration and so on that allows kind
of push button reproducibility
and so in in threading this concept of
the research compendium which which we
imagine as like a bundle of files we
could deliver to another researcher and
they'll just be able to make sense of
what's going on and reproduce or audit
the work
we're coming into you know the sort of
challenges that um that were outlined in
the in the in the proposal for this
session it's like where are the
conventions
should we settle on one and we're
finding that you know the smaller scale
obviously there are totally different
conventions to make the most sense for
ones that we were thinking of a research
compendium to a company like a journal
article for example
and so we've been exploring those i've
been exploring my teaching and in
publication as well
and i've also been engaged in in my own
research as prehistoric paleolithic
archaeology mostly in southeast asia but
also a sort of side um theme on meta
science in my field where i every time i
see a paper that's published with code
in my field i will take a good look and
keep a list of it and trying to see what
kind of norms are emerging in terms of
people struggling to make their work
more transparent reproducible so rather
than
latching on to a convention that's
that's
emerged out there and just trying to
dictate to that i'm more interested in
seeing like what is what is this the
least cost path that people are
navigating through this challenge
and then communicate them abroad and say
hey like maybe post a tweet or something
here's a cool paper someone else wrote
that i don't know
but they've done an amazing job of
getting their code and data so well
organized this is something that anyone
could do
and hoping that that will that sort of
more ground up sort of norm amplifying
approach might be more productive than
than a more prescriptive approach let's
see still still over the days for that
so that's enough for me i will
pass to uh is it uh yasin jonette is
that the correct pronunciation i think
that's our last
person on our list
uh yes yes all right
thanks
hi uh hi everyone it's great to be there
with all of you little daunting to be
the last one to give the presentation uh
but very very impressed about everything
i've been hearing obviously
uh so i'm
i guess here with kind of two hats
one is i'm a researcher at hugging face
which is a company that does open source
software of
both models and data
especially started with language
processing but now
in many more domains
and in there i'm working in a team
that's recording data ethics models and
society to work a little bit more about
the context for the technology and the
context for the choices we make
so that's one hat and the other hat is
uh ad big science we have been hosting
and part of a project called big science
which is not really the most imaginative
name but
i mean sizes of the essence it really
says what it's about
and which started
inspired by that stochastic products
paper that i'm hoping many people have
read here
about the limitations of having very
small labs with very little diversity
making all of the decisions about
training those language technologies
that are going to affect many many
people
and taking another point of view which
is that as many people as possible
should be working on those in the open
uh so we were very lucky to get a
compute grant and the public
infrastructure to train some of the
model which was already an answer to
some of the
criticisms there
and there's currently 700 of us from 56
countries working on many many aspects
and
within this
enterprise there are five different
working groups that are specifically on
data
so we have working groups on data tubing
working groups and data sourcing what
data gets included
on data governance which is such a wide
big topic
on legal scholarship we're lucky to have
not only technical people but also legal
scholars
people with background in sociology
thanks for example valentin has been
helping
and
philosophy
and
working group for privacy
so yeah so lots going on there at
hugging face we are more on the applied
side and providing software are using
which means that there's a lot we need
to uh think about uh what we're doing
and what we're prioritizing and the
norms that we're gonna be setting we've
been doing a lot of work on for example
normalizing uh model and dataset
documentation
following recommendations from the data
sheets and data statements papers
and at the same time working on
automatic tools for
analyzing data linking models that
they're trained on and
we're an open source company so more
than making rules we provide tools that
we think are going to make it
easier to implement more responsible
practices and that are going to
inform people about what they should be
maybe thinking about
uh right so that's and there's a
continuous between that which is
applying the research and the technology
that has been developed and uh on the
big science more of driving the research
and driving the research agenda from the
ground up and from the source uh from
the choice of the data from thinking
about
uh who has a say and should be involved
so i'm mostly working on the data
governance suspects
and there we've been like taking this
aspect of uh i mean echoing some of what
experience brandeis has said about being
intentional at every step which is that
everything needs to be opened and needs
to be a choice that's made
about
so we're talking about data data is
people people have rights
how does every of our choices impact
people's rights which rights are we
talking about so we're putting ourselves
within a human rights framework but also
acknowledging
the limitations of a human rights
framework sometimes
and trying to take a self-critical
approach beyond that
and implementing a data governance
structure that is informed by all that
and there i'm also going to echo some of
what ben was just saying about which is
that
rather than writing these papers and
disposition papers about what other
people should be doing that is
corresponds to responsible ai
we're writing norms for ourselves and
for the practice that we're having and
hoping that that's why
first we're informed by the orders that
we find
and second we can set a bit of an
example and prove that yes you can
actually do things in a way that's
uh more self-critical and responsible
wonderful
it's been great to hear so many
different perspectives and yet
commonalities and
um
important dimensions that that kind of
cut across domains and expertise i think
it seems to me that uh where there is a
common point is that we do need what
kirsty mentioned this continuous
integration
across that goes
um integrates those technical data
analysis
to
other dimensions including
reproducibility and transparency and
open science and then connecting to
those ethical dimensions and also harms
what brandis marshall
uh mentioned and so i think one question
that we can explore a little bit more
will be what kind of challenges are in
this continuous integration so because
when we uh
see what kind of packages what kind of
tools we are we are very good at
for example reproducibility and
reproducible workflow i think we now
have well established tools
and
for for transparency and reproducibility
and
the workflow
would work across different open source
domain softwares
but how do we integrate this to the
ethical dimensions how do we actually
evaluate harms and then
actually bring back and so also from a
causal inference and design perspectives
people were saying well it reproduces
well but is it true is it actually this
data analysis
um
focusing on what we should study which
is actually from the
um
kind of from the start of the data
analysis and some of the ethical
questions are also from the start but
also at the end in terms of
harms and and social impact and so i
think um
one one they mentioned here could be to
just examine what what are the gaps
where this
um
continuous integration is kind of
hard to do it and
where should we
work more to bring
both communities and
perspectives not just tools
together so that
we have
indeed this responsible data science
workflow where
reproducibility works well with ethics
and
kind of they merge together and i i
totally agree that we're out seems to be
doing that and thinking through that but
focusing more on the gaps will be
probably helpful as the next steps
oh i raised my hand i wasn't sure how we
were going to do that but
like like we're in like we're in a class
um so
i i think i think rules are open and we
can actually
uh i'll
talk and chat and have a conversation
and we can actually redefine the rules
because we have two hours
for some of us is very late in the
evening so it's definitely informal
conversation and actually my wife has
today birthday party so it's
for me definitely
um a wonderful day from many
perspectives so go ahead okay okay cool
i'm glad this is going to be pretty
informal so
i think that when it comes to
understanding the alignment between the
two the workflow and the ethical
components
there is this tension that is kind of
innate and how we learn the scientific
method right is that the scientific
method is very
sequential and linear and that at the
end of one stage will wrap up and it
will begin a new stage right and so that
means that you can't really go back
um but what happens inside of the
software development life cycle
is of course that there is a lot of
feedback loops
and i think that
notion needs to be brought forward a
whole lot more is that there is an
evolution and when you learn more you do
better and unfortunately at least in
undergraduate curriculum in the united
states the software development life
cycle really doesn't hit
the students and undergraduates
psyche until like toward the end of
their college days
and so that means they spend if they go
to graduate school they spend most of
their graduate school time and then if
you go directly to industry you spend
your time in private or public or civic
sector then grappling with the fact that
the scientific method is a great
framework but it doesn't translate very
well practically
so ethically we need to have this
conversation
is that things evolve
that is part of science um
and and then we can actually now form um
the idea that having um
having that feedback loop in every
single cycle within the the data
workflow is a natural
expectation not something that you have
to fight against
so
that's something that i i hit on quite a
bit when i'm talking to adults because
they've been in the classroom learning a
certain way and then i'm telling them
well you know that doesn't work right
it's kind of like writing code by
yourself you're taught to do that in
school but when you get in the real
world you're typically coding with other
people you're looking at other people's
code
commented or not sorry pet peeve i like
commented code um
and and then you are playing off of
someone else's understanding and style
of how to code that's not something
that's taught in school but when you get
out into the real world you therefore
have to contend with that so i think the
ethics is is the ethical layer is a as a
layer that needs to have
more
involvement in the education system but
also be more upfront when it comes to
the workflow about there's an evolution
of how data is perceived how it's
manipulated
and then what the outcomes are and even
the language that we use calling them
answers when they're not answers or just
outcomes
so it's a this whole scientific method
pins us to think that there is one
solution but it's not a solution it's
just an approach
so even the language that we use
is setting us up to be very
narrow-minded and and close when
actually we need to be more open so that
we can hear the other voices and then
and integrate them
more seamlessly and without friction
yeah i mean thank you i mean to bring
out that discrepancy between the
you know scientific method and software
development i i see it pretty pretty
much every day um
um
i'm working with researchers and then a
lot of them
work in code and oh my god it's not
doing what it's supposed to do you know
and this i can feel this sense of
failure
like it's a math problem that you're
trying to solve and there isn't one or
you know this is either you could get it
you get it right or you get it wrong
then software is not like that software
you get it wrong all the time um
and then it's part of software
development to go through that
at first
trustration you know it's fixing the
software until because the computer is
telling you that you know you got it
wrong and you need to change something
or maybe you realize afterwards but
trying to
get that message across that um
spending time on on code and then and
redoing things going back to things is
is what it is really there's no escape
from that um
then the problem is um
um you know when i
work with phd students and postdocs
there's a problem of time
because the time that they spend
fixing the software or making it
refactoring this idea of you take
software that already works and you make
it more readable
um
that there most people understand the
value of that
um from ethical perspective
um because you would actually want
people to use your software and you want
to benefit contribute it to your
community
but then where are the incentives um
because as per stocks and phd students
um
there's a there's a very high pressure
to publish papers and produce the
science the plots that you want to put
in your paper because that's what's
going to
br to be creative bring bring food on
the table this is going to what it's
going to bring
make your career advance um
and so i see that although most people
agree
with these concepts and practices is
quite rarely done
and a lot of people
at least in research a lot of people do
code by themselves
there are a lot of people code
collaboratively but there are also a lot
of people who are writing their scripts
on their laptops
and these scripts are rarely reviewed by
other people
and often rewritten by the next php
student
i can i can jump in on on this um
i
i want to um plus one
very strongly brandeis's uh position and
i think it's what's really interesting
is it actually goes all the way back to
like the way that you learn um
math science
art history um
whatever language or literature you're
you're engaging with all the way from
like the very sort of foundations of
school
and you can think about like gender
biases in sort of what does a scientist
look like what does it what does a
programmer look like and
one of the things that i think um
those ideas are really sort of if you
pull on the thread far enough back you
get all the way back to sort of
well if there's a student who is um
13 years old let's say um and they
really they like thinking about complex
challenges that are naughty and thorny
and and there isn't really a clear
answer and you know you can think so
history i feel like is that that's like
my sort of go-to one with that you can
kind of reflect on it and learn and how
would you learn what would you do
differently things like that
and actually what i think the
conversation around data data ethics is
really making so so obvious is those are
the people that we need working in the
data science teams and one of the big
worries that that we have to sort of
as a society under un undo i suppose
is that those people will quite often
define for themselves as being not
a scientist not a programmer not
whatever that category is and so
i do think there's this i i bring it up
i think to sort of highlight that
it it really goes a long way a long way
back and it goes deep down deep so very
many layers of biases that we have in
our in our society
i think that's where um
to some extent if people are thinking
about
this
and they're thinking about responsible
research and innovation
and i think if anyone thinks that it's
easy to do
then i my position is that they have not
spent enough time thinking about it
because actually really really when you
deeply dig into it um i i give talks
occasionally and i had a slide on one of
them where i said that for open science
to succeed we have to together dismantle
the patriarchy white supremacy and
capitalism and that's you know if you
wake up in the morning you think what do
i got to do today what's on my list and
you think well those are the three that
i have to i have to dismantle um and so
that's a big piece of work
and i i think i think actually
recognizing how hard it is is really
really important because i think any of
the sort of
quote and quite easy solutions are um
i think they give us a false sense of
secure sense of security
however i sort of want to bring in sarah
i don't know if sarah if you want to
sort of jump on this because i think one
of the things that you said in your
introduction which i think is really
really important is
the
perfect the all or nothingness that some
of our conversations around and even the
sort of badging of like
ethical
not ethical
it doesn't really make sense because
it's a much more sort of
multi-dimensional consideration and it
will be
beneficial
for whom
to whom does it distribute power to who
for whom does it consolidate power and
um and i don't know sarah if you want to
sort of jump in on on how you think
about kind of
stepping people up to
completely dismantling a system so that
um tibolt's
position that you have to write papers
and papers of the things that are going
to put put food on your table which i
think is true right now
but i think it's a responsibility for
all of us to dismantle that incentive
that it is no longer true and and i
think we probably all agree on that
front but yeah sarah i don't if you
wanted to be coming on that
yeah sure thanks i honestly like i have
nothing no wise answers for this but i
struggle with this myself and then to
teach students it's like
um
right like i
i
how do we both espouse the value of like
we're heading towards this like perfect
like it's it checks all these boxes and
knowing that getting there
you have to fail to get there
and so is there a situation now hearing
you all i'm thinking maybe if i've tried
i have tried to myself be like okay what
are checkpoints like good enough here
good enough here and i struggle with
that but maybe it's a balance of like
what is good enough
is related to
the potential impact your work is gonna
have on others right so like maybe
that's the way to bring in students it's
like okay the stuff we're doing as much
as i want it to like impact the world
some students project is maybe not
harming has not the same opportunity to
harm others as something else so maybe
there is this trade-off of like okay
let's think about what are the impacts
of what you're doing
what can we agree is a good enough
practice here
and like can we feel good about that and
like oh you're taking the next class and
like let's let's up the ante of the
responsibility aspect let's try to do a
a project that maybe has a bigger impact
and then we have to also up our
standards of where we're at and maybe
that trade-off of like
what
where does this thing this outcome go
can inform these sort of checkpoints i'm
seeking of like
you can you be 25 there and be happy at
this level can we be 50 there as sort of
this way to
to not have people feel demoralized
before they can even
get there right um i think that goes for
researchers too like you said if i only
have so much time
can i pick one checkpoint that feels
good for my situation
and that's a step it's not perfect i
want to do better but maybe that's
a path forward and
i would love to you all should tell me
what are these checkpoints i should be
passing on to students
um
because i just find it so hard myself
it's just like i only have so much time
to teach this thing what is the thing i
should teach and then i get in this
moral quandary of am i teaching the
right thing did i you know shortchange
whatever and
but
anyway now i'm monologuing please
somebody save me
um
i i did want to
jump on that a little bit uh on a couple
of people
uh one of them is that
one of the so students are not
necessarily the best people to
affect that change because they have
less agency than many of the other
practitioners but they do have a choice
of what they decide to work on and what
they decide to focus on
which can make and then that's a small
chance that's going to change what
topics are normalized or recognized
which can snowball into like shifting in
the end not by themselves but as part of
a pattern what people think are
acceptable research topics for example
um
one of the other things that i wanted to
mention there that i thought about was
uh so dr marshall before talked about
the need to also be on the tech policy
side
um
and we do have kind of that like two-way
relationship between uh technology
practitioners and technology policy
where technology policy works with
what's possible within technology and at
the same time technology needs to comply
to that uh so i think the whole like
data statements and model cards example
that recently showed up in the eu ai
policy
is a very good example of that of
machine learning technology
practitioners working on those possible
tools and then those being organized as
something that yes needs to be needs to
be provided
and just to oh sorry
go ahead yeah oh so just to add to some
more some more
some more things
if you're if you're looking sarah for
some some guard rails a little bit so
number one i don't think there is a
checklist i don't think there is like a
25 45 85 i don't think that's ever going
to exist because technology is going to
evolve and so is the software and the
open source basis of what all the
software is based on so but anywho
um there is fair f-a-i-r
um so that's a scientific framework i
can't remember out of the nih i believe
um from a couple years ago
that does provide some scaffolding
in order for have some idea of how to
make
technology
i hate the word fair so i'm trying not
to use the word fair but to be a little
bit better when it comes to
understanding and awareness of the
issues that are involved there's also
care ca
re um and that is really centering the
indigenous communities and and how to
make sure that they have data governance
so some of that framework is is nice to
to share with a student population
again there's no checklist with all of
this but it does provide students with a
awareness of what they need to be
looking out for and it's love it's
they're pretty short works and pretty
digestible and good for conversation um
the last type of resource i would uh
suggest is uh
blind spot ai
blind spot ai
does have
sort of these it's kind of like the the
model cards
but it does go through
a couple of different stages of what to
look at during different phases of
design
it's specific for artificial
intelligence
but i think it could be extrapolated for
other
parts of the coding
metaverse sorry i use metaverse
sorry about that
which i'll understand
great great i i very much like this
distinction between science where work
is fragmented and what dr marshall
mentioned the work is fragmented and
then in software engineering where there
is this
evolution and development of
a project and
i think
most of the
the problems come when we think about
this at the individual level because we
individually as scientists we have to
and
okay that was 10 years ago now with open
sense we much more discuss
that
um publication papers numbers of papers
is not the most important criteria but
it's still a pressure as uh timbott
mentioned for many phd students to
actually deliver
but this is the individual level and i'm
thinking here when communities are
brought together like for example big
science
and um
that you seen mentioned
will actually have different teams that
focus on different aspects and they
actually try to coordinate and work on
those so as individuals we are
fragmented but probably we can create
these social institutions that
do the coordination although every one
of us is very limited same for ben that
now he's trying to bring together this
program of data science and to
coordinate between humanities data
science
data analysis and ethics and
for for brands as well in terms of
communities so she's involved in this
and and i know kirsten
with the the turing way uh trying to
bring also communities together and so i
just want to hear more
what would be those broader social
sociological
communities that could actually resolve
and solve some of the problems of
fragmentation
of the
scientific
results and outputs where we are limited
with single papers and
without building broader
um
a broader um
outputs and how communities can actually
save us if they could
you think do you want to start with big
science and how this is
coordinated and what kind of lessons
are there for yeah of course uh my
entrance is acting up so i think i heard
about 85 percent of what you just said
right now um
but i mean i also obviously very much
agree with the stress um
one of the things that has come up as
the really important ingredient here is
um
there is a very strong role
for grassroots communities to play
uh which
makes a lot of
questions of legitimacy right what does
what makes them
what counts as a grassroots organization
where do they get their legitimacy for
from how do they report uh
who's part of the effort makes decisions
um
ben do you want to when do you want yeah
thank you um i was going to say about
the question of the types of communities
that could be useful for
um
tackling this problem of fragmentation
just to raise the one that some of you
may be familiar with the communities
called our open size those amongst our
users
and so they originally grew out of
writing our packages for accessing apis
for data providers
and then became a sort of community that
organized also unconferences to bring to
mix people together from industry and
academia and
and they were very carefully uh very
selective and who they bought to get
these meetings like novices and then
people are very experienced and so on
and it's kind of grown into like a
software quality control community as
well where they have an agreement with
the journal of open source software that
i'm sure many of you are familiar with
that kind of tries to occupy the space
between software development and
academic sort of credential
for that for that labor and the our
openside community have developed sort
of a manual of how to write our packages
that will be compliant with the journal
of open source software and and sort of
um achieve high standards of software
engineering as well so this kind of
community i think is a good example of
that
of a group that are helping to resolve
some of these problems they have
converged on the
our package
as a sort of technical convention
for doing their work for accessing the
apis and also
as a sort of research
unit as well that com that works well to
treat in our package as a compendium i'm
not sure quite and there's some
disagreement about this in our community
and i don't know what the equivalent
things would be in the python world but
they've certainly been very successful
in creating a like constructive
and
satisfying sort of space
and community for discussing and
debating
how to solve some of these challenges so
so that would be something i would uh
i've enjoyed being part of and and would
recommend for the python community
as well yeah
you seen do you want to continue your
time
exactly how much of what i was saying
made it just wanted to
insist on the ability to have people uh
who do not have as much institutional
access
or technical creds uh or whatever to
have a voice in those spaces
uh which is why i was really putting on
the grassroots aspect and also uh
having like good community standards a
good code of conducts like all of these
things that actually have a strong
impact in making sure that the right
voices
are heard and getting those uh
principles and centers wonderful and and
going back to just to to
big science so the question is is more
or less
what
what do you gain when you have different
teams working on those topics and they
can coordinate
although none of them could actually
solve so some of them will work more on
the technical others more on the
data ethics and representation or harms
and do you think that
um this could be a kind of a solution
for the fragmentation problem that we
discussed on the kind of as video
researchers we all face
i mean i i think it very much does but
i'm also like preaching for kind of my
own project there so but the things that
i'm really glad to see happen is that
uh some of the problems will be surfaced
by one group working on one paper that
are more related to another part of the
pipeline or the part of the research
infrastructure so someone working on
modeling will find something that's
wrong with the way that data is handled
someone working on data will find
something that's wrong with the way that
contestation mechanisms are enabled
which is like
from tooling to governance um
one of the things also that has been
important i think in that project it
goes back to what other people have been
talking about is that we're talking
about a project that is all in all a
year and a half
which is still comparatively short but
is longer than what a lot of grad
students have for a project
which importantly means that there is
time to revisit
decisions that have been made before we
knew better
without endangering the whole project
and i think both that transversal
exchange between people with different
specialties and the ability to have uh
what people say directly impact how the
rest of the project is going to be run
uh is very important and unfortunately
that's not quite something we get with
like conference papers right because
like someone publishes a conference
paper that puts those results somewhere
and everybody who has been like between
the first six months before it was
published and three months after that
working on their own project don't
really get those insights until uh
it's maybe a little too late to shift
their projects
yeah just as an antidote i had a whole
like twitter rant about the way
conference
papers uh conferences do their review
process that it is not sustainable at
this point
um the whole reading
typing
and and then submitting to this this
vacuum black box of people who then make
a decision of who
whose papers get through and whose
papers don't um
so i think
to a larger question is the whole notion
of publishing papers and how it should
be done to actually
provide a model for more equitable work
and transparency and accountability so i
think using zooms
would be a great way in order to have
this conversation so that students who
are in those short-term degree programs
like master's degrees
don't spend a year and a half
doing something that they do spend a
shorter amount of time can can produce a
paper
um send it out have a committee like
this right a group of researchers who
read the paper can provide that feedback
and then the person can make changes
adaptations and and get a paper
published
but again the whole system
the whole it's a white supremacy system
anyway
because it doesn't benefit anyone but
the the white guys that are able to have
you know paper mills
so they have 50 graduate students doing
the work and their name gets slapped on
it so
that whole
system needs to be un just just
burned up anyway because it doesn't
really help a whole lot because there's
papers that get through that really
don't do any good
right
papers that will change the way someone
looks
skin tones of what people look like
change what someone is wearing
and it's always women who always get
their faces changed
it's always women who get their clothes
removed
their faces transpose
it doesn't it doesn't
help tech's
reputation anyway
so
that's just my little rant i can go on
forever on that but i will stop here
but the whole system just needs to go
away like writing a paper doesn't mean
anything because if your paper is not
impacting anybody if it's not actually
used
then what's the point of you writing it
just because it's cited doesn't mean
anything either because someone can cite
your paper you can cite your own paper
and it doesn't mean that it's actually
being used or causing any type of
benefit to anyone in society so
the whole holy grail of writing a paper
um is something that
education systems
need to dismantle
quite honestly because it doesn't help
at all
it really doesn't help
all it does is just
regulate the same people to publish
papers and they have their friend help
and they help their friends publish
papers and as someone who has written a
lot of papers that have been rejected
i can tell you a lot of my ideas have
shown up other places and other people
have gotten credit
so
i think we need to really think through
the importance of writing papers and
really re-center the importance of what
impact that paper is having so data
sheets that yassine has mentioned
multiple times
has is it doesn't have any experiments
in it
it's like five pages
and it has made a lot of impact
it needs to be in more cs curriculum it
hasn't gotten there yet
but it's on its way
that's an important paper that's one to
write the sarcastic parenting paper
guessing mentioned that's an important
paper
gender shades that's an important paper
it's making impact
right um but these esoteric papers about
um
scanning in the faces of your dead
ancestors and seeing their faces move
not so sure about that one
or the fact that there are faces that
are being made based upon the
characteristics of other people's faces
don't think that's an important
technology that we need to have so i
make it off my soapbox before i really
start saying some really radical stuff
thank you yeah better please
hi if i can just jump in the
conversation
i
would like to
put three ideas over the table
um
first
i get you with the
paper
[Music]
overload i
don't come from an academic background
i have
done some research that people of the
uh
i don't know how do you see an academic
industry of the
academic disciplines have found
interesting and
new knowledge
yet
for me was impossible to publish because
i don't have the degrees i don't have
like they know the
industry jargon even
a
good
pharmaceutics friend
told me that i should
translate my plot into the
pharmaceutic
standard colors
which are not the
standard by vuki which are
the
colors
which are more optimized for neural
perception but anyway
so i think that the all
paper production pipeline is pretty
rotten right now
uh i just want to introduce i don't know
if you're already talking to two ideas
one is the
hippocratic
german for data scientists i don't know
if you have heard about this
sorry for the spanglish i have the title
in spanish but the point in
english
which i like to resume to
to say that the role of the data
scientist in the organization instead of
giving security and assurance to
everybody else that we have this super
uh
model with it's going to be 99 if it
is all the country to give doubt to the
rest of the organization like we have
this model but have you thinking
minorities we have this small
um in my current work
we have this
tracker for people
in order to understand
uh if they have pay or not the
transportation authority card
and
my first uh
response to the
commercial guy was okay
you do you want something that will work
in people with two legs and two arms
that's not all the people
but just a big fraction whatever but
you know your product is gonna be
attending that kind of people
and in general
about this hippocratic journal
i feel that the suggestion is to give us
the role to
give doubt to everybody else instead of
give assurance
and
the other stuff that i wanted to
put over the table
is this like uh
i know it's pretty naive but this five
item leaves uh from
ah what's the name of uh
of katyanim
that algorithms should be auditable
and transparent
available
improbable and
and
really regulated
even if if it's a internal regulation
like in my home we don't do biometrics
that's my home
uh and
where i work um
in my company i have
we have this policy that we don't do
non-consensual
biometrics
so
when they sell
some user cases that include that
uh
we say okay not that case it's not gonna
be there because
there could be children there could be
a mentally
mentally
challenged people which are
not in a position to give a consent so
you cannot
simply do a
biometric extraction or of every phase
that
go in the way
and to to to close
uh
these uh ideas
i i like to get this um
concept that
ethics is a responsibility of everybody
not just
the coder not just the salesman not just
the academics it's
everybody
please destroy my ideas i want your
feedback i want to grow this
i'll say i completely agree with
everything you just said vera i believe
it's everyone's responsibility i think
the trouble we have is that not everyone
is knowledgeable about the role in which
they play so they don't understand the
level of their responsibility and that
gives them cause in order to not be part
of the conversation
they say it's someone else's issue right
it's kind of like the focus of a lot of
data programs is on
um
on students like there's a big push for
younger and younger students to
understand data
when adults don't understand what's
going on
so
you're trying to tell
little kids how to be responsible about
data but adults aren't doing it so the
kids have no model
so you're then pushing the problem
pushing the can down the road 20 years
so everyone is responsible but i think
we're now at a point
an inflection point in which the
education
and not just being literate but being
engaged needs to happen
by everybody
at all levels of an organization be it
academic government civic
or public sector
that's my two cents
i um
i agree with i agree with that and i
agree uh very they you your position as
well the thing that i wanted to
highlight is
the organization where you work
the fact that they have the courage to
say no
to
opportunities so getting data in that's
you know that's been collated and it's
been provided
and i think that
is one of the biggest hurdles that we
all have to um kind of grapple with and
it fits as well it fits very strongly in
the kind of continuous integration kind
of idea as well
because if you are going to
continually so on a somewhat regular
basis
reflect on the work
reflect on whether your work is
your team's work
is achieving the purpose that it was
designed for
minimizing the harm
and
if you're going to do that really
then you have to also be able to stop
that project at some point
and i think that is a problem it's a
huge problem in academia because of the
funding models that we have and because
of the timelines along which we um
kind of expect people to show output
but i also i think it's not just an
academia problem so i think you know we
could you could fold that in very
strongly with the kind of like
funking pdf papers online behind the
paywall
in the year of our lord 2021 is the most
the ridiculous use of the internet ever
but i think it's so i think it's so much
more than that because if you take it
into like a startup sort of space
someone's gone around and sold this ai
they've they've you know raised money
they're paying their staff
and if actually it turns out that the ai
harms people that you know facial
recognition is obviously you know sort
of a canonical example
then
where is the where is the motivation
for that organization to say
okay
our whole fundamental principle is is no
longer what we're going to align behind
and i think that's where for me so i
said at the beginning that i work at the
national institute in the uk the
national institute for data science and
artificial intelligence
and i think this is where kind of
courage needs to come from our funders i
think it needs to come from governments
and then i think we need to sort of lead
by example and be transparent about the
things that we stop doing and i want to
also just bring back a point that sarah
raised right at the very beginning so i
i agree that most academic papers
are
have very very little value although i
think they have a huge amount of work
that have gone inside of them but i
think in terms of the impact that they
make in in the world
i think it's very small but i did want
to come back to a point that sarah made
at the beginning
i think communicating
is is
more important just as important as it
ever has been we just need to think more
carefully about the medium through which
we're communicating and so for me that
would be thinking about how do we
incentivize documentation right
documentation for data documentation for
code and documentation for kind of how
they came together in an analysis
documentation around the limitations and
the caveats how do you sort of explain
that
how do you explain
many audiences policy makers and other
technologists people who are going to be
affected by algorithms that have been
developed
how do we how do we really meaningfully
explain what has been what has been done
and involved them in in the decisions
going forward those are all
communication skills they are they have
huge impact in the world and and i would
love it if we sort of
expanded our definition of what it meant
to communicate the work that we've done
to include all of those so it's not this
i had a meeting earlier today with a phd
student that i supervise and she has
multiple supervisors and we were having
a discussion about writing in the active
voice or the passive voice and she has
some supervisors who are very very keen
on long sentences and the passive voice
so
data was uh ingested and analyzed as
such well rather than we analyzed data
we found this result
um
and i think i think those
those discussions are kind of they're
holding us back and they're keeping us
they're keeping us
really sort of
inside of a very narrow definition of
what it means to communicate and i would
love to see
more communication of things that didn't
work
more sort of celebration of projects
that were stopped
and one of the things that i really love
about working in an open source
ecosystem
is that so long as you're working in
quite a modular way
it sounds really hippy-dippy but like
the journey is
part of the deliverable so if you are
working in a public github repository
everything exists all of the learning is
there
even if you stop the specific project
and you might pivot it to something else
and so thinking again going back to that
point about kind of thinking of the
scientific life cycle as this very very
sort of iterative process
and
really cheesily really really cheesily
thinking about everything that you do
along the way as being something
valuable rather than
the answer as brandeis was saying the
answer at the end that you then go away
and tell people
yeah i i couldn't agree with this um
but i i can't stop thinking
of sort of to kind of take these ideas
and see like so why aren't we doing this
um
and trying to look at you know how what
were the people around me
the one thing i was thinking about is
this this demands to
think on the on the long term
like my bit of my research my so my
research like my contribution to
research even if i
some the the the software i write the
research note
no conclusion or the conclusion is that
there is no conclusion i don't know but
you know this is going to benefit
the field and the science on the longer
on the longer term but it's very hard to
think
on that long term when your contract is
six month or year long and so i think
that um
you look at institutions where
contracts are longer or sometimes
feminine then then
it changes everything because
then there's a lot more room
a lot less pressure
um to to to take on that work and to
think of you know
longer term and
but then
in yeah in most of the institutions that
i'm i'm familiar with
as as postdocs most postdocs are
employed
for a year or two maybe three
um
and that limits your your vision um as
again now as an individual because you
have it forces you to think as an
individual
um so how do we how do we cope with that
and i mean obviously now you know it's
at the level of an institution it's good
but uh yeah i just i just had that in
mind like how can we how can we
implement these ideas
when most of the workforce the workforce
the who's producing research the
means of research are actually employed
quite precariously
i would like to just jump in here and
encourage anyone here in the uk to vote
to join their union and vote in the
upcoming ballot to um take strike action
for exactly this precarity problem it's
precarity across so many different
levels but the postdocs are particularly
affected and i completely completely
completely agree and i think it's also
important to recognize that it's not the
post-docs problem to fix and that's
something that's really important but
it's it's not the people who have the
least power in the system even though
they're at the they're at the cold face
they're at the front line so they could
implement you know reproducible uh
notebooks they could write better
documentation they could do all these
things but it's really
it's really important to recognize that
it should not be their responsibility
for exactly the reason that you will
said and then sorry the other thing i
want to just highlight because
we have a we have a large research
software engineering team at the turing
institute
and i want to to highlight the
just how radical the concept of a
research software engineer so and see
what was talking about it earlier and
that's that's your job and you described
it really beautifully but most research
software engineers are designed to be
flexible
they're designed to be able to work
across lots of different projects and
they should be although not every team
across the uk is they should be on
permanent contracts and so suddenly you
now have
very talented expert people who can
collaborate broadly who have the
technical expertise whose jobs are not
determined by the number of citations on
these pdf papers that are behind
firewalls
their jobs are determined by whether
they help others to deliver the really
high quality work and the more permanent
positions we can get
across all of data science
the the more likely we will start to
work on longer time scale and i think
it's unbelievably important to start
investing in that
wonderful wonderful probably we
we could discuss some of the questions
that we have
in the chat
so let's start with the one about
reproducibility and thousands where the
main push for reproducibility should be
coming from from education from journals
and i i would like to extend this a
little bit and think
about the different areas that we're
interested in including ethics
and representativeness of data so those
other dimensions what is their
different push actually because i think
they're slightly different as we know
for example from some areas in
psychology it's uh
it's been
some some evidence of reproducibility
crisis and then more or less internal
push from the scientific community to
address those issues for some of the
other
topics that we discuss is probably a
different push and so yeah
i would love to
have your thoughts
so one idea on that topic that is uh
absolutely not from it and integrated to
uh deborahgi uh
was that uh one of the things about
being transparent is that it explicit
you to being predict
and the question then is then what right
um and one field that has been doing
good work of that is uh mechanisms for
reporting security flows in software
where like you
are incentivized and required to report
those flows in a way where you are
giving an opportunity to fix that as
opposed to being punished for reporting
them uh
obviously again like on my id but that's
something that we can definitely talk
about more in how we implement those
processes
great yeah i think this also goes back
to what vera mentions the first point
that
we should focus more on on doubt instead
of assurance on instead of certainty and
to focus on uncertainty and not being
penalized for that but rather being
acknowledged that
we understand
the bounds and the levels of uncertainty
that
any
uh particular result or our estimate
will give and and to acknowledge that i
think here going back to the water the
pushes for transparency reproducibility
is
that scientific findings typically are
especially during covet are
um communicated and discussed broadly
with the broader community and so one
dimension is whether this
exaggeration and and spin is among the
scientific community or from papers to
the broader the broader audience and i
think there were examples of both of
those but
there are some
initiatives that at least
acknowledge and argue for
giving more voice to uncertainty and
[Music]
limitations of research but i i i agree
that in terms of reproducibility and and
data sharing
in the scientific community there still
more penalties rather than those
constructive tools too
for constructive criticism that's
actually continuous integration and
update rather than
binary decisions whether that's good or
bad
and i wanted to chime in to say reduce
reproducibility i think is a
conversation and an action to be taken
at all the stages
so it's not just one or the other so
education you do the toy version of it
but then inside of organizations you do
like the grown-up version
right where you do have critiques you do
have penalties you do have constructive
criticism that then you're folding in
so i don't think it's just in one spot
for reproducibility but at the the end
of this question
talking about journals and reviewers i
think that there
is a
layer that we don't talk about which is
the labor of reviewing
and that labor is free labor
and that free labor is of people with a
whole lot of degrees and not a whole lot
of time
so
i think a structure in which
um
the review the reviewing process in
general is not reliant on free labor
because it is a lot
to review a paper um
and to review a journal to go through
the steps
i have not been part of a review process
on a journal or conference paper where i
had to look at reproducibility like
actually running code and things like
that so i don't know how that process
would be done and what that those steps
are would be curious to know if anyone
else on the panel has any idea about
that but i think that there is a a
separate
question here about
the free labor of reviewing and so if
you are doing something for free you
have 10 of these things to do
there's only so much time you can
dedicate to doing a
a
thoughtful
complete
full comprehensive review of the work
in order to bring out the critiques and
to also not be in more the penalty box
because your
rate of bias in how you see a paper
depends on which order of the paper
you're reading and how many papers
you've had to read over how many days
just being quite honest
so
you know i i think there's just other
other things about reproducibility here
when it comes to review that we have to
talk through as a scientific community
if we're really going to address some of
these issues
on the question of peer review i think
that's a fascinating
element of the process where we have
this great challenge of the tremendous
burden that potentially
gets much higher if we have these
demands about reproducibility and
openness there's so many more things to
look at and run the code or not or
whatever but i also think the other side
of that challenge is that it's also a
wonderful opportunity to just
move the needle a little bit
and in the course of doing the peer
review say well you know i can't really
do a proper review of this paper because
i can't see the data and code that
generated the figures and either stop
the review right there and then give the
editor this kind of
issue of like well do i then do i then
raise the expectations for reviews
generally and make this author send me
this stuff to review
or or continue on with the review for
example i will face this challenge you
know if it's a junior scholar then whose
work i really support will say well this
would be better if it had the code and
data available but here's some other
thoughts anyway and you know good luck
with the paper if it's a senior scholar
appear i would say this is it you know
show the code of the data i'm not doing
any more review for you until until it
comes through and i think
that it would is a useful thing that is
cheap for us in terms of time and effort
just make declaring those values around
peer review which helps to communicate
to editors
they're usually the kind of people that
we need to wait to retire or die or
there can there's going to be change in
that part of the way that journalists
run
but these are values that are shifting
and emerging uh in
in sort of professional communications
and i really like the way um
kirsty talked about communication is
kind of central
part of the challenge of improving
reproducibility and the peer review
process is just one little channel we
have to communicate in a really profound
way
because editors desperately need the
peer reviews and and reviewers will kind
of
uh you know do it walk over broken glass
to satisfy the requirements of reviewers
in in many cases so i think there's an
opportunity that we should be like on
one hand to be sensitive to the burden
that it's going to create but also to
exploit in a way that will further our
you know further the the sort of
sustainability of transparent practices
in the discipline so yeah really
interesting um avenue of practice that i
think is underutilized by people who
value these things yeah things
so another topic i'd like to touch on
here that actually goes back to some of
what ben was talking about in his
introduction about designing a data
science program that has
other epistemic processes and other
sources of knowledge
is the role that we give to
investigative journalism in who is
critiquing the work that we do
and where they're coming from
um
because for example uh i i've been
working a bit on the technology of
automatic content moderation and that's
where like that's who's pointing the
limitations
often more than ourselves as technology
like participants
um
i'm going from an nlp but i'm sure that
there's like other experiences that
other people have had in other fields
or going back to the gender shed which
was more of an integrated effort between
researchers
public presentation and journalism
if i can jump on the
ripple segment issue
uh i think that the
knowledge consumers
uh
we're gonna moderate and
in 50 or 100 years
you're not gonna believe anything that
is not
fully reproducibility
reproducible
but also
like the second step because it's gonna
be fake news if you cannot reproduce it
it's just like this
but
one very important issue in
replaceability is that
you can i i come from the devops world
so
when i
got into data science i was in shock in
the decreased crisis of reproducibility
of
knowledge or of official knowledge
and i'm very kind to the dvc tools and
ci tools
that allow you to
just do a git clone and dvc repro
results by the steps something like that
one of my best student
which is also doing a master
her
[Music]
master professor
said that was the
most
easy project in his life to just run it
because
the ci tools allow you to do that but
that only checks that
the code
and the data version that was used for
the code do
something
but it's not gonna be really really
validated until somebody else
changes something and say okay your
method is cool but
what happened if i use exactly your same
code
for the method in my data set or maybe
your
three initial step of dataset are cool
and the seven
lasts are cool but i want to
change something in the middle
and that is the research
or knowledge
if you just public sign node in papers
that is
giving trust
to the original research that that what
you did is not only reproducible in the
sense of the code that can run but also
each step is scientifically
sound so
i can change just a part and get
something current
i don't know if you follow me i think
i've seen
some work on this like it's called the
multiverse where it's essentially like
your paper but you allow your people
like somebody can interact with your
paper and and all the decisions you make
try something else so like i did a
t-test here what if i had done
you know a fancier t-test that accounted
for this thing and it sort of like lays
out this framework for
sensitivity analysis to all your choices
and then if your paper still reads the
same we're like happy that seems good
that's like i guess
replicable if we're making those
annoying distinctions between
reproducible and reputable
um i'll i'll try to find a link and put
in the chat but the idea that yes if you
make it easy for people to change little
things in your work and still get the
same answer
that's sort of like even better that's
like
maybe reproducibility plus and like
tools for that i think
i'm
i only know of this one tool i'm
thinking of but that to me sounds
interesting make it easier not to just
click a button and reproduce your
results in this situation but let's be
easily toggle with
things i might not agree with like oh i
don't i don't buy this that you took out
these outliers what if i put them back
in could i quickly see what happens
keyword quickly there i guess
do any of you have better
tools for that because i'm nosy and
would love to know
i don't i don't i'm sorry i don't have a
tool
uh sorry um i um
but maybe it ties to the idea of you
know if you publish or if you
contribute something do it in small
chunks
um
instead of
because if i you know when i in my phd i
i
just i just didn't publish a lot because
i published one massive paper
and that was that was just a big mistake
because you know it's completely
unreproducible to be honest um and
because it's you know from start to
finish because you
you really wanted to you know view the
full picture and publish the full thing
because
yeah
you know and then this this this idea of
you know if you oh we don't want people
to just to start doing what we're doing
you know it's kind of like my my
research my work and i could feel this
kind of like
atmosphere around
um but maybe if you change that that
approach and then you say well
i'm going to publish what i'm going to
share or
um
the the past few months of work and
this little chunk
and then then somehow when you feel like
okay now i i think i finished my project
then you
you have a series of
contributions that it can tie together
and so now if people if you want to
change the piece it's clear how you go
to that reference that paper or that
contribution to
that software package
so instead of a maybe a tool uh they're
probably tools that allows you to do
that maybe in a more gradual
granular level um
um
i was
listening to a python podcast
recently and they were talking about a
um
it's not a pipeline manager and it is
something close to it it's called kedro
and then we're explaining how
it's something that allows you to kind
of wrap
functionality into nodes and then you
build your pipeline
from different nodes but that's a much
on a more technical level but maybe at a
higher level um
starting to
value smaller
smaller more frequent contributions
i i just want to
jump in here i totally agree with all
the with all of the points i want to
bring in another dimension which is um
a lot of our conversation
around reproducibility is assuming that
everyone has access to the data
and
sensitive data i think it was um you
seen who is saying
fake they choose about people there are
people represented inside of that and
they may not have chosen to
have given
well
if you're for example if you're scraping
social media
um they didn't none of those people
actually
gave consent for their for their words
to be used as part of a research project
um in other cases you know i do some
work on electronic health records
and people may be
willing to have their work be used for a
certain per that would be have their
health records be used for a certain
purpose
but not necessarily for everyone so a
big example is that there's work that's
been done by the welcome trust and
talking to lots of patients and members
of the public
that
in general patients who are represented
in the in the health record system in
the uk
are pretty pretty happy for the work to
be used by researchers
they're also quite happy which some
people will find surprising
or their data to be used um by
pharmaceutical companies
the organizations that they really don't
want to have access to the data are
insurance companies and you know once
you say it that way you're like yeah of
course the pharmaceutical industry could
come up with something like i don't know
a covered vaccine that would really
change the world and make life an awful
lot better
academic research i don't know quite how
much help well it does it there are
there are papers that do have value they
tend not to cause a huge amount of harm
um but i think insurance companies
really do have a huge amount of sort of
potential to cause harm
and so the point that i want to raise is
most
it's maybe a little too strong but
data that is really valuable and i don't
mean like you can sell it for a lot of
money i mean that it has a lot of
information inside of it that our tools
would be our algorithms would be able to
kind of
elevate out to give us meaningful
insights into the world
um
i would argue that most of that data
should not be made
openly available so health record data
financial record data um
even personal sort of text i think we
have to be much much more thoughtful
about kind of
why people have made that data available
and for what purpose and so
that has been my
biggest barrier with reproducibility
it's actually the data governance it's
actually getting people access to the
data
and we have two uh
veins of work um inside of my program at
the turing institute one is thinking
about um
reproducible and redeployable
and reusable
extendable scalable all the fun words
uh trusted research environments so
actually being able to to spin up
including all of the governance
procedures
um
identical or customized to be sort of as
needed trusted research environment so
you have the hard shell that sits
outside you are very focused on you're
very careful about who has access to the
data inside
but
what happens inside it can be the same
as in another trusted research
environment so you build some
interoperability between those and that
would allow us to start to think about
things like federated learning across a
secure research environment network
and then we also have an area of focus
on synthetic data
and there's really interesting aspects
around synthetic data for sort of
some people will think about how close
you can get to the to the real data and
there's uh there's a sort of catch 22
that you get there the closer you get to
the real data the more likely you are to
leak personal information from the real
data so you get into this kind of
where do we draw the line and we we have
a research project at the institute
that's led by martin o'reilly who who is
literally trying to sort of come up with
determinants for where you do draw that
line and under what circumstances
but what i'm really interested in with
synthetic data is actually not
how do you get synthetic data that is as
close as possible to the real data
but how do you get synthetic data that
allows you to work in a very
collaborative space something very much
more akin to working openly so that
people can see the data they can
interrogate the code they can change one
of the decisions along the way and see
what effect it makes
but then you still
take your pipeline once it works and you
map it to inside of your trusted
research environment and then you run it
on the real one and then you have to do
some sort of comparison between those
two things but that allows many many
more people to get started to
interrogate the algorithm to really
understand what's going on
without
the
i'm going to use the word burden but i
think it's really important to recognize
that that the
responsibilities the legal
responsibilities we have around
protecting access to data
they're real they're not they're not
sort of um for no purpose
they're there to protect the rights of
the people who are represented in the
data sets but if we can start to sort of
modularize how and why people are
working on
the real data if you want to have the
real answers that sort of you know come
out
or some of the development work that
could be done on something that looks
like synthetic data i think that's a
really powerful step forwards for us
that would allow us to sort of extend
some of some of the purposes of
reproducibility extendability
reusability
without necessarily having to
explode the number of people who can
actually see
individual rows of people's financial
records or people's health data for
example
wonderful yeah i think that's a
go ahead yeah i was just going to say
that that the
the reproducible the abuse of
reproducibility issue and and how that
dovetails with personal data privacy is
always a very interesting conversation
um because of the nature of what is
considered sensitive and what to
sensitively mean to different people
right
because certain people might think that
their
gender identity is sensitive and other
people don't think their gender identity
is sensitive some people think their
disability status or veteran status is
something that is sensitive and other
people don't so
understanding what is
the personal data privacy conversation
is is a very interesting one
the other comment that i had was
um
the
the kind of
shadow boxing um
with
synthetic data versus real data is very
much a
symbolism of
just
the basic issues when it comes to
sampling biases so
it's entering to a stage of you know do
we have the right sampling of the
population
that is in the synthetic data that is
really something that's representative
of the real data so we
it's a
problem that we've seen before within
the scientific community and therefore
we we have an idea of the challenges
what are the challenges that are still
open and the challenges that have been
semi-resolved as far as approximating
things so
um as someone that is
marginalized in several different ways
in data because i'm counted like three
times in data um
i think it's important in order to have
baseline conversations about how people
with different identities are really
represented inside of any data set be it
synthetic or real um
because
i'm counted as i said like three times a
black woman an american
and so
um
my
everything that's around my data it's
pretty easy to know who i am it's pretty
easy to identify me
there's not too many black women in
computer science with phds there's like
100 in at least the united states so
it's not hard my name is
pretty unique
there's two people named with my name in
the united states so um
so
the characteristics of people in the
data
um and how you model that synthetically
versus how do you model how is that
represented in in real data becomes a
whole nother question as i said that's
very uh very much akin to
sampling biases that do again harm
people that are unique and are on the
outliers because all of scientific
method is going toward the majority and
the majority don't look like me
absolutely so sorry to interrupt this
awesome uh
discussion we could stay here for more
three hours
but we have five minutes left just want
to remind you on that
absolutely thank you thank you
probably we have just time for final
remarks i wanted to bring one of the
questions if we want to to discuss
because we we chatted about different
solutions some of them related to
community
other
related more to communication and i
think one of the questions brings
the role of
regulation and so how we compare data
science in general to medical practice
and should we have actually association
to accredit data science practitioners
so this is a question by brian and i i
think that's uh
if if you have any thoughts about the
role of regulation and about data
science practices and
if you have any thoughts of that
i want to bring you what oh sorry go
ahead
no it's fine i was going to say i want
to bring in brightness because someone
else earlier um commented about some
principles that teams could could align
to
um and uh brandeis said that it was a a
performative gesture and i i want to
sort of
i'm really curious to hear you hear you
expand on on that a little bit more
i think there's a
there's a possible counter to saying
that it's a performance of gesture which
is that every journey is made up of lots
and lots of little steps so potentially
if we can get even just a few more
people to think a little bit more
carefully about sort of what their
responsibilities are that could be a
strength but i'm i'm very open to you
saying that um
that's an overly naive and that we are
just sort of patting ourselves on the
back by signing a signing a list of
principles that can't actually be
enforced in any way so maybe i'm
preempting your arguments a little bit
there but i wanted to just open open
that up for you
oh that's funny um so yeah it's just
patting yourself on the back because
there's no call to actions um and so
with with with no actions there's just
chaos um and
and nothing in just stalls it stalls any
type of behavioral change and without
behavioral change nothing is going to
happen so
yay for signing but there's nothing
being done that's actually making any
impact that's what i have to say about
that um when it comes to
the question that you pose uh valentin i
think that certifications
come
along with it a lot of social economic
understandings
and that means that there is money
in this and who is going to be leading
the charge if it's not a black or brown
lead organization leading the
certification charge then i don't want
anything to do with it
and it shouldn't be any anything other
than black or brown let period the end
that's how i feel about certifications
because any certification by
anybody else is just a money grab
so
and since they won't give money to black
people or to brown people then therefore
certifications won't happen so that's
the end of that conversation that's how
i feel about that okay final remarks
thoughts
so i i did have one thought about uh
that goes to what both chrissy and
brandeis have talked about
um
a lot of the conversations that we have
about what we should do are about what
we should do still assuming that we
should be making those decisions and
making those choices and deciding what
the principles are
whereas in a lot of cases a lot of what
we can do is build power out so like
agree on who else should be making those
decisions
um so sometimes it's just so we talked a
lot about transparency transparency is
one of the ways we do that right is by
like giving away our privilege to just
what we do in our corner and opening
ourselves to having other people tell us
that we're wrong
another thing is uh having uh opt-out
mechanisms in technology
which means that we don't keep our
captive audience that needs to pay for
our services but we give them the option
to uh without the penalty decide not to
participate and we also have them a
feedback mechanism of people actually
like not participating if we're doing
things wrong um
so yeah i always wanted to
mention that at some point in that
conversation
wonderful
thank you so much for being here with us
we really appreciate all the discussion
thank you for being at pi data global
thank you so much
thank you
you